one of the biggest remaining challenges
in AI is that most machine learning
models that we train are uninterpreted
that means that when we train a neural
network it is really hard to figure out
why it's making certain predictions this
is okay in most cases but many
applications like self-driving cars or
healthcare or cybersecurity they're very
crucial and they require us to actually
understand why an algorithm makes a
certain decision and so to address this
really important issue of
interpretability I want to bring you
guys a series where we will discuss how
neural networks are learning and what
they end up learning after training so
the first part of this series will focus
on feature visualization and various
ways that we can look into a network
after it's been trained and actually
look at what it ended up learning while
training on some tasks in the second
part we will look at various examples of
how neural nets can be easily fooled to
make the wrong predictions so here we
will talk about adversarial examples
that clearly show that even though these
networks are loosely inspired by how our
brain works there are clearly some very
different things going on and then in
the final part I will cover a few very
recent papers that discuss the trade-off
between memorization and overfitting
versus generalization strengths on
unseen and new data and how all of this
relates to you know the learning process
that's going on in neural networks are
you ready to dive in deep my name is
Xander and welcome to archive insights
so imagine we have a trained
convolutional network that can do image
classification the problem is if we want
to understand what is actually going on
in our network the only thing we see is
a whole bunch of matrix multiplications
and a lot of math going on so very very
difficult to interpret that result
meaningfully now luckily there are
methods available to look inside that
magic black box let's start with feature
visualization so the simplest thing you
can do for future visualization is
simply look at your network after
training feed it a whole bunch of images
and then look at the activations inside
your network if we take one specific
neuron out of our network for example
and we feed a bunch of images through
our network most of the times this
neuron will not fire but in some cases
when a particular pattern is present in
the input image our neuron will fire and
we call this an activation and basically
this neuron is saying you know hey guys
I saw a very particular pattern in the
input and that might be useful for
classifying this image in a given
category so take a look at these images
for example what we've done here is
we've taken four neurons inside a deep
neural network and then we've looked at
all of the training data images and we
selected nine images for every single
one of those four neurons that maximally
excite those neurons and from these
samples we can already get a really good
idea of what a neuron is trying to
detect and so before we go any further I
want to know that this approach is not
only limited to visual features so in
this fantastic blog post for example by
somebody LeMond who now works at google
deepmind a very similar thing was done
for audio let's take a look so the whole
goal of this project was to see if you
can use deep neural networks to do music
recommendation so traditionally music
recommendation is done with what we call
collaborative filtering and this means
that you're simply going to look at what
a user likes so you're going to look at
the music that someone listens to the
playlists and their likes and then
you're going to look for similar users
that have a very good matching of those
likes and playlists and what you're
going to do then in collaborative
filtering is simply recommend songs that
person a likes to a person B that is
very similar in music style but there is
one problem with
filtering the problem is that if you
have an entirely new song there is no
way to know who likes that song and
therefore you cannot even apply
collaborative filtering we call this the
cold start problem and one solution to
this problem is to use a deep neural
network to take a song and map it onto
the same embedding space that you would
end up while using collaborative
filtering and so the whole idea is that
you take your song in audio form you map
it onto a spectrogram which basically
transforms your audio file into an image
and then you use a deep convolutional
neural network to map that image to an
embedding space that you would get while
using collaborative filtering and if you
can do that then you can take any new
song that nobody has ever listened to
you can run it through your deep neural
network and you get a representation of
that song that you can then use for
recommendation and it turns out that if
you train a deep neural network to
transform an audio song into the same
embedding that you would get using
collaborate filtering that this deep
neural network learns some very
interesting features that are present in
audio so here we're going to do exactly
the same as for the visual features we
take one specific neuron and then we're
gonna run a whole bunch of songs through
our network and we're gonna look at
which songs maximally excite our
selected neuron so the first feature on
the top left for example learns to
recognize women singing vibrato tones if
you listen to a couple of the samples
here this is very very interesting
because all of them have a very similar
kind of feel to it
and you can sort of understand by
listening what this neuron is trying to
look for
caress me another neuron here for
example has learned to detect the drums
in drone base songs kind of cool right
so while these examples give us an
intuitive idea of what a network is
trying to learn it can be a little bit
confusing because if we look again at
these examples here if you look at the
dog faces for example well it's kind of
hard to tell is this neuron trying to
detect dog faces or is it simply
triggered by a pair of eyes and take the
one image on the right for example is
that one looking for a sky in the
background
or is it detecting buildings in front
there really is no way to tell for sure
if we want to figure out what our
network is really learning will have to
do better so one of the first
influential works on feature
visualization was a paper by Matthew
Siler and Rob Fergus in 2014 so what
they did is they trained a normal CNN to
classify images but at the same time
they also trained a backward-looking
network that try to visualize what the
features were learning so here's how it
works you run an image through your
convolutional network but for every
activation of a single layer you're
simply going to take that activation and
use it to reconstruct the activation of
the previous layer we call this ad
convolution operation you can train this
with normal gradient descent using a
very simple reconstruction loss so to
visualize a given feature after training
all you have to do is feed an image to
the network pick one activated neuron
then set all the other activations in
that layer to zero and use the trained
backward Network to map that feature all
the way back to the input pixel space so
instead of visualizing examples of
images where a certain feature must be
present using this technique we can
really focus and accentuate the specific
parts of an image that activate a chosen
neural and this gives us a much more
detailed view of what's going on so
let's have a look at some visual results
so here we can see
a bunch of layers from a deep
convolutional network being visualized
where the first stack of images shows
the reconstruction in the input space
and the second stack shows the actual
images that were fed to the network so
in here we can already see a lot of
what's going on we can see that the
first layers in the network they detect
very simple things like lines and edges
and then the consecutive layers what
they do is they build on top of those
very simple features and they build more
complicated structures and all the way
at the end of your network you have very
complicated features detectors that are
combining all the information from the
previous layers and these things are
detecting features that are very useful
to classify our images into the final
output labels I want to note however
that using this technique you have to
feed an input image to the network so
there is no way to visualize a feature
without feeding it a specific input
image now since the very early work on
feature visualization there have been a
couple of very successful new techniques
one specific approach uses gradient
descent itself on the input pixels to
generate images from scratch that
maximally excite a chosen neuron let's
see how this works so we start out with
a randomly generated image every single
pixel here is a random number and then
we're going to feed our image through
the network we're gonna pick one
specific neuron that we want to activate
and we're gonna compute the gradient
using back propagation and basically
this says well how should I change the
pixels of this image to activate that
neuron a little bit more and so by
adjusting these input pixels with
respect to the gradient of that specific
neuron if we loop this for a couple of
times we can actually generate an image
from scratch that is very very good at
activating that specific neural so here
we can see an example of what happens
when we do that for a couple of thousand
iterations and so the main difference
here is that we don't need an actual
input image we can simply pick a neuron
and then generate an image that would
maximally excite it and by being a
little bit creative we can also create
images that minimize the activation of a
given neuron so here you can see a
couple of results
where on the left side you know there
are images being generated
that minimally excite this neuron on the
right side we try to maximize its
activation and then in the middle you
can see examples from the training set
that do both of these things so the
results here are really interesting to
look at and going a little bit further
we can even generate images that excite
two neurons at once really cool right
and now before we go on I want to
mention that even though these generated
images they look really nice and you can
sort of feel what the neuron is looking
for actually generating these images is
not as easy as it sounds it's not just
backpropagation there is a whole bunch
of different regularization techniques
that have been tried and it's mainly
these regularization techniques that
affect the way that your final generated
image will look like so for people that
are interested in knowing more about the
technical details I would definitely
recommend to check out this blog post by
this still because it is amazing
alright so all of this work on feature
visualization has led us to this very
common and intuitive understanding of
what deep neural nets are doing the
first layers they recognized very simple
patterns in the input data and then as
you progress through the layers of your
network all of those very simple
features are recombined in different
ways by the neurons in the next layer to
get to more and more complicated feature
maps and at the end of your network all
of those feature maps are complicated
enough that they can be used to detect
specific classes in the images and so
over the years a lot of people have been
working on feature visualization and I
want to highlight one specific work that
I found really cool it's the deep
visualization toolbox and so you can go
through the github page and basically
what they build is a system that you can
use to analyze what a deep neural
network is seeing in real time so you
can hold a couple of things in front of
the camera and you can actually look at
all the different layers in that network
and see their future activations in real
time as the network is analyzing the
input images a couple of really
interesting things to notice is that
here for example we can see that the
network learned to detect text in images
but an interesting note is that it was
trained on the image net data set which
doesn't have
an output label for texts so what this
means is that our deep neural net has
learned to recognize text in images even
though that text itself is not an actual
output class and so it turns out that if
you look at the training data text is
actually very useful to predict classes
like bookcases or traffic signs and
being able to find text in an input
image can be very useful to label such
images and to finish off I want to show
you guys one cool example of what you
can do with feature visualization let's
look at this very cool project by a
Google engineer called deep dream and so
what happens in deep dream is that you
take an input image and then you're
going to feed it through the network
pick a couple of specific neurons and
then you're gonna use gradient descent
on your input pixels to gradually adjust
the image in order to activate those
chosen neurons as maximally as possible
we see here if we start by picking
neurons in the lower layers that we
actually get enhancement of those
features that the first layers are
detecting so very simple things like
edges and lines but if we pick features
in the higher layers we can start
recognizing specific objects like faces
and eyes suddenly appearing inside the
image and that's why they call it deep
tree and so you can see that by picking
features visualizing them and messing
around with the code you can create some
pretty cool examples all right so let's
recap what we learned if we take deep
neural networks and we train them using
back propagation on some data set they
end up learning very very simple
features in the first layers and then
consecutive layers will start
recombining those features until we get
very complicated feature representations
that can be used for the task it is
trying to learn the easiest way to
visualize features is to just look at
training examples that maximally excite
the chosen neural a better way is to
generate images from scratch using a
gradient signal to maximally excite a
chosen neural and the advantage here is
that you don't have to deal with all the
correlations in your input data you can
just visualize a feature itself but when
doing this regularization is key alright
so that was it for
to visualization in the next episode
we're gonna have a look at adversarial
examples and these are images that we
can generate but when we give them to a
neural network they get completely
misclassified into the wrong label and
while this is not exactly what we're
hoping for these things can give us some
very interesting clues on how we can
still improve these neural networks I
thank you all very much for watching and
I hope to see you again in the next
episode of archive insights